long time listeners of the think media
podcast and our VRA fam know that we
always say reasons come first results
come second the root word of motivation
is motive
so what is your motive for starting
YouTube in the first place is it to help
others you know if you're measuring
growth
and it is to help others think about the
subscribers and the views you've already
gotten has anyone left a positive
comment thanking you for your content
maybe your goal is to reach millions of
people or billions of people but
celebrate the one that you've encouraged
or that you've helped celebrate the 10
that you've been a moment of inspiration
or a moment of education for did you
start to express your creativity
are you creating content to capture
history and Legacy why do why do you
want to do YouTube what is your motive
for doing YouTube and remember your why
when motivation is low to keep fighting
for that goal even if you're not
experienced experiencing growth you want
to rekindle your passion ask why are you
excited about this why were you excited
about this in the first place how can
you discover and ReDiscover your love
for just content creation period
whatever happened to the days when we
just made videos for the love of making
videos whatever happened to the days
when it wasn't all about just money or
algorithms or views or trying to beat
your prior best or be a one out of ten
on YouTube and I'm obsessed with all
those things but I definitely think I'm
in a conversation like this could be so
healthy to just kind of come back to the
why